次にあるところはね そんなに難しいとこでもないし
別にきめ細かく説明しなくてもいいところですと思いますが
このなんて言いましたっけ？プッガラベーダ
いろいろ角度で物事を見るんだから
どんな人にどんなチッタ・ニヒティが生まれるかということなんです
まあ人ではプッガラっていうのは生命だからね
ドゥヘトゥカーナン アヘトゥカーナンチャ パナ
これは二十六番目なんです
百十七ページの方 ドゥヘトゥカーナン アヘトゥカーナンチャ パナ エッタ キリヤ ジャワナニ チェーヴァ アッパナ ジャワナニ チェ ナ ラバンティ
タタ ニャーナ サンパユッタ ヴィパカーニ チェ スガティヤン
ドゥッガティヤン パナ ニャーナ ヴィパユッタニ チェ マハー ヴィパカーニ チェ ナ ラバンティ
で まあそこでこの生命にどんな心が
どんな心の道ですね 心の道が生まれるかと
この道はセットで生まれなきゃ認識にならないんですからね
ですから 道セットで考えてるんです
ドゥヘトゥカーナン アヘトゥカーナンっていうのは
この生まれる心 生命が生まれる時
生まれた心にの問題なんですね
ドゥヘトゥっていうのは二因身
アヘトゥカっていうのは無因身
二因身・無因身っていうのはこの貪瞋痴・不貪不瞋痴なんですね
因というのは ですからこの
まあ明確に言えば 貪瞋痴の場合は痴と貪
あるいは痴と瞋 漏婆とモーハ
あるいは漏婆とドーサとモーハ
モーハは基本的 善の場合は二因というのはア漏婆とアドーサ
不貪と不瞋 三因というのは不貪・不瞋・不痴
三つの だから善と悪と分けると
悪の場合は無知は確実にある
善の場合は無知の反対の智慧は確実にあるわけじゃないんです
これはこの随分昔説明しましたからね
六因ですからね 漏婆 ドーサ
モーハ で それは不善の場合は
大体不善の場合はいつでも二因か一因なんです
こちら三つあるんだけど
現れる時はモーハと漏婆
あるいはモーハと えーと
ドーサですね ですから
不善の場合はいつでも
あの 二因 あるいはモーハだけ
モーハだけだったら一因になっちゃうんです
ですから 貪りと無知の痴
怒りと痴 あるいは痴 その順番で
善の場合はア漏婆・ドーサ・モーハだから
二因か三因なんですね
二因になる場合はア漏婆
アドーサ そこで二因になっちゃうんです
三因の場合はこの三つも
3つもまとめて三疑になっちゃうんです
ということは アローバードーサ2つさえあれば善心ですし
それに智慧も足せば三因の善心ですね
でも無知がなければ不善はできない
智慧がなくても善はできる
その善行為 悪行為をする時の
その心に入った心想によって
また生まれ変わる時 自分の運命が決めちゃうんですね
悪いこと 不善を行って人が生まれる時は
二因身で生まれる 二因果身ですけど
二因身で生まれるか 無因身で生まれるか
どっちかなんです 無因身は十八の中に入ってあったんです
心の一番最初の説明で
例えば 人間ではダメですね
不善身で生まれる場合は
不善身の結果として生まれる場合は
人間では生まれません
生まれるのはこの四つのアパーヤですか
四種類に地獄の次元 四種類に分けてますから
苦しみの次元 そのどこかに生まれるんですね
動物の世界か 阿修羅の世界か
もうそれから餓鬼道か
地獄 地獄そのものか どっちかと
そちらにいる人々の生命の心は
生まれた心が 正気心が不善身の結果ですね
と言っても ほとんど無因身ですね
やっぱり心がないんで
このセットの中でこの二因身の移熟身はないんです
不善の方で二因身 移熟身はこの八十九の中には入ってない
入ってないんだから 地獄の次元に行く人々はみんな不善移熟身の七つあります
無因身七つ その中にある一つの心で
サンティールナ  サンティールナ
サンティールナという心で生まれるんですね
そこら辺はチャートなんか見ればすぐわかるものですからね
覚えなくてもいいんです
人間の場合はちょっと違うんです
人間の場合はやっぱりこの善位熟心でないと善位熟心でないと人間で生まれません
善位熟心の場合は無因心一つもあるんです
善位熟心の無因心一つあります
それから八種類の善位熟心の中にも認心は四つあります
そこで人間は生まれるんですね
その心いくつかで 人間で無因心で生まれる人間というのは
もういろいろ人間らしくない生き方で生まれるんだと
人間で人間は人間なんですけど
やっぱり人間やることはほとんどできない
生まれつきこのいろんな障害を持って生まれるとかね
手も足も自分の口も自分で動かせないとかね
死ぬまで誰かにご飯を食べさせなくちゃいけない状態とかね
というふうな大変なこの悲しい状態で生まれる人間もいます
で そういう人間は形は人間ですけど
人間やることはもうほとんどできないでしょうに
しゃべることもたまにできないし
考えることもできない子も生まれるし
例えば脳細胞もね いろいろ障害を持って生まれたら体も動かなくなっちゃうし
それは一因心 一因のサンティールナチットクサラウパーカ
アヘットクサラウパーカ
サンティールナチットで生まれるんですね
で 普通の人間はだいたいの人間というのは二因心で生まれるんです
あの八種類の善位熟心の中に
あの智慧非相応心が四つあるんです
ニャーナビッパユッタチッタが四つあるんです
智慧が入ってない心が四つある
智慧が入ってないんだけど
布団不心は入っている
それは普通の人間なんですね
だから鋭い智慧はだいたい普通の人間にはなかなかないんです
ただ言われるまんまで
教えられたまんまで まあこれは美味しいと言ったら美味しいと自分の頭に刷り込まれて
それで美味しくなっちゃうし
あれは綺麗ですよと教え込まれたら
それは刷り込まれて それでああ綺麗やと決めちゃうし
もうちょっと先に飛んで考えるということはしない
そういうのはだいたい一般的な人々の生き方でしょ
それは二因心の人間 三因心っていうのは布団夫人プチ全部入っている
この善位熟心の四つの心で生まれる人々なんですね
その人々っていうのはすごい鋭い観察能力は持っているんです
他の人よりは で もう体格もよろしいし
そんなにもう問題もないし
で すごくこの物事の観察能力はもうものすごいシャープなんですね
それは三因の人々というふうにアビダルマでは分けてます
ここで言っているのは
この何心？二因心の人と無因心で生まれた人々には何かできないんですね
何ができないというと
キリヤジャワヤができません
ユイサ心の即行心は生まれません
当たり前のこと いわゆる悟れませんということなんですね
無因心で生まれたら まあ人間の障害者か地獄の次元でしょうか
そこはもう悟ることは不可能なんですね
ドゥヘイとかってのは二因心というのは人間では生まれてしっかりはやってるんだけど
そんなに鋭い智慧がないんですね
そうすると瞑想したってもサマーディも生まれない可能性はあります
まあ普通に人間として何も問題なく
まあ言われる通りに行動すると
なんか天才みたいな新しい何か考え出して新しい何かすることはできないんだけど
まあ学校に入ったらそれなりに勉強するとかね
試験が迫ってきたらそれで勉強して試験は合格すると
大学も卒業すると でも抜群に何かやったっていうことはもうない
で 会社に入ったらそれそれなりに仕事をしてまあいると
そういうのはまあ二因身の人々
そういう人々はまあ瞑想したっても
何かサマーディなんか生まれるという可能性はないと言ってるんです
まあはっきりないとは言ってないんだけどね
まああるテキストではできるとも言いますし
アビダルマテキストではできないとも言ってるし
ですからキリエジャワナはありませんね
とにかくアラハンになったらだけキリエジャワナが生まれますから
唯作心の諸行心 それからアッパナージャワナーニチネラバンティ
アッパナージャワナーっていうのはこの禅定の心
禅定の心も生まれませんと
そこで過去世の善行為によっていじくを結果は味合う場合はいじく心というんですね
過去世で善行為をして
その結果をここで味わうと
それはいじく心なんですね
このチッタヴィッティの中で
それは可笑縁として入ってるんですね
最後にセットの中で最後に可笑縁出ましたでしょうに
可笑縁ですね で もし二因身の人が普通に立派な人間で生きてるんだけど
過去世でやった善行為の結果を受ける場合は
この可笑縁は生まれるんだけど
可笑縁心が その可笑縁心がいつでも智慧非相応可笑縁心なんですね
智慧相応可笑縁は生まれませんと
ということで 別にまあそれでどうたっていうことはないんです
地獄なんかにいる人々には可笑縁生まれても
決して善行為の結果としての可笑縁は一つも生まれません
それから次に三因の人の場合はどうですかと
三因で生まれた人間であるならば
この神々は三因だとは
三因ですかね 人間は二因三因両方ありますけど
二因三因一因 三つありますけど
天国にいる神々は何でしょうかね
天国も同じなんです 二因か三因なんですね
天にいたんだからって三因になるわけじゃないんです
欲界の中だから そこでこの瞑想できるのは三因の人だけなんですね
三因の人が瞑想して もしアラハンになったならば
生まれない心があるんです
それは善心と不善心が生まれません
アラハンになった人には善心と不善
愚善心は生まれません
ということは 種類 の不善
愚善心はアラハンには生まれません
種類の善心も生まれません
欲界の種類のサマーディ心も生まれません
無色界の四種類のサマーディ心も生まれません
阿羅漢になったら唯作心しか生まれません
それは善唯作心八と色界の唯作心五と無色界の唯作心四があります
それぐらいしか生まれません
ただ 心が似たような心ですけど
似てないんですね 例えばいいことをすると
阿羅漢の一人と普通の人の二人が組んで何かいいことをすると
で 普通の人にはそれによって善心が生まれるんですね
阿羅漢はいいことはするんだけど
別に心の中は全く空で
全然善心が生まれません
不善心も生まれません
ただ唯作心だけ 行動のみ
ですから そういうジャナが出てこないということ
次にセーカプトゥージャナーナ
セーカっていうのはこの有学舎でしたっけ
有学舎そうですね 有学舎っていうのは預流
道預流果 一来 道一来果
不還 道不還果になった人々には有学というんです
なぜ有学と言うんですかというと
さらに進まなくちゃいけない状態にいるんですね
だから仏教で有学というのは確実に聖者のことなんです
悟った人のことなんです
まだ悟りは完成していない
第一段階目  二段階目  三段階目にいる人々には有学という
無学というのは四段階目に行った人
阿羅漢には無学というんです
他の人々には凡夫というんですね
悟ってない人々に それは神であろうか
梵天であろうか 悟ってない人には凡夫という一般の生命という意味で言葉使っているんですね
輪廻を超えてない生命として
だから生命を三つに分ける分けると凡夫
有学 無学なんですね 凡夫っていうのは輪廻にいるすべての生命
有学っていうのは預流果
一来果 不還果になった聖者たち
無学っていうのは阿羅漢果になった聖者たち
そのグループの有学と凡夫には唯作心のチッタリイティが生まれません
阿羅漢だけのことだから
繰り返すことですから
それで有学の人には不善心は生まれます
預流果になっても不善心は生まれます
まだ煩悩残っているでしょうに
それでも 例えば欲の心が生まれたんだと
欲の心が生まれても そちらにはこの嫌憎相応の心が生まれません
ディッティガタサンパイという心は生まれません
嫌不相か非相応ですか
悪見不相応  悪見 悪見不相応の欲心は生まれ
欲貪瞋心は生まれる可能性はあります
見はない 邪見はない 悪見はないと
それから疑 疑いの心 それはこの疑の心っていうのは痴根心に入るんですね
痴根心二つあります 一つは疑の心
疑いもないと しっかり真理知っているんです
すべては無常であるということ
ですから疑いは生まれませんし
そういう心は生まれない
不還果の場合は怒りの心も生まれません
こっち書いてないんだけど
不還果には 貪瞋心も生まれるかな
まあ貪瞋心が生まれるように書いてますけどね
わからない 不還果には貪ると怒りは両方消えますけど
弱まるって書いてあります
え？ 弱まるっていう テキストだと弱くなる
弱くならないって書いてあります
え？ 弱くなるけれども
完全になくなってはいないっていう
テキストだと  うんうん
まあその可能性もありますね
なぜならばルーパーラーがルーパーラーがありますから
この欲界の欲界・無色界に対する煩悩はまだ残っているんですね
ですから やっぱり貪瞋心が生まれるでしょうね
まだまだいくらか性に執着しているんだからね
完全に悟ってないんだからね
その分は貪瞋痴がやっぱり生まれるんだ
そこで出世間心は そのその聖者にそのその時生まれるんだと
預流果になる人 瞑想して預流果に悟る人にとっては預流果の出世間心二つ生まれるし
で まあそういう風に生まれるんだと
それはこの人によって現れる心の差なんですね
まあそこら辺明確に説明しちゃうとあまり混乱しちゃうし
そんな難しいところでもないんです
どんな人間にどんな心が生まれるということではないんだろう
どんな生命にどんな心が生まれるということじゃないということは
一応言いたがってるんですね
そこで三身因 三因の心で生まれたならば
可能性はありますね 修行して禅定を作る可能性
悟る可能性はあるんです
可能性はあるんだけど
もうやらなきゃ生まれません
次に次元によって どんな次元でどんな心が生まれるかという 二十八番目のブーミ・ディバーガ
で その生命の次元ということは
この仏教では皆様が聞いている言葉
残骸ですね 三害 残骸ではなくて
三害という言葉で まあよく知られてるんですね
三つの次元があるんだと
これ三つといってもすごい大きいんで
一切の生命は三つに分けてるんだから
一つは欲界 もう一つは色界
もう一つは無色界 欲界っていうのは体があって心がある
それで体から認識している
我々は欲界 我々に体があって心がある
我々はものを体として知っている
物質として知っている
ですから欲界と言うんです
欲っていうのは欲という意味ではなくて
この眼耳鼻舌身の対象に対して知っていることなんです
我々の頭の中の考え方なんか全部外へ出してみちゃったら
全部聞いたものについて
見たものについてでしょうに
感じたものについて すべての妄想概念見たら
ですから 我々の知識っていうのはもう体を通して得た知識なんですね
ですから欲界と言うんです
人間は欲界 神々も欲界
神々の世界六つあるんです
地獄は四つと 人間界は一つと
神々の世界は六つと 全部十一次元があるんです
このすべての十一次元をまとめて欲界と言うんです
そこで次の次元は色界
色界っていうのは瞑想の次元ですね
第1 第2 第3 第4禅定を作る人々が生まれ変われる次元は色界というんです
その場合をなぜ色界というかというと
体があるんですね その神々に
その梵天に 体があるんだけど
認識は体としてでもないんです
禅定の認識なんですね
だからずっと禅定の喜悦感で喜びで
もう何光年もいるんです
で 禅定は四つですけど
梵天は四つだけではないんです
たくさんあるんです  第1禅定に入る人にも梵天は三つあるんです
ブラフマパーリサッチャ
ブラフマプローヒタ マハブラフマと
そういうのは後から出てくるだろうと思います
アビダンマでも  第2禅定の場合も
パリッターバ アッパマーナーバとかなんとかとか
また三つ三つぐらいあるんです
禅定の一番 あの第4禅定の梵天はアカニッターという梵天に生まれるんですね
それはアカニッターっていうのは頂上ということで
もう生命として次元の頂上
これ以上はもう生命としてもう
もうないと いわゆる体を持ってる生命として
体と言ったって 私たちみたいにこの
もうすぐ腐る体を持ってるわけじゃないんです
すぐ腐るんだったら 一光年あるいは八万四千光年いられないでしょうに
光年というのは宇宙の一回転でしょ
宇宙が現れて消える一回転は一光年
もしある梵天が二十光年生きてるならば
我々と同じ体だったら
もうこれはもう一ヶ月間でもう腐ってしまっちゃうでしょうね
だから物質と言っても
体と言ったって我々に想像できる体じゃないんです
まあ素粒子でできた体でしょうと思いますけど
素粒子で 素粒子でできてならば
まあ宇宙は破壊になっても素粒子としていられるんだからね
素粒子は破壊になりませんから
まあそれはまあ 私の勝手な考え方で別に仏教で言ってるわけじゃないんだけど
えーと ですから色界っていうのは体があるんですけど
認識は禅定として認識している
無色界っていうのは体もない
ただ心だけ そういうことで
その無色界の梵天と他の生命とはもう何のコンタクトも取れないんです
まるっきりもう私たちからはもう綺麗にカットされてるんです
我々たちとしたって もうどんな生命とも
何のコンタクトも不可能なんです
その人々が自分の心だけあって
その心が禅定の心だけ作って
ずーっといるんです いると言ったっても体がないんだから場所もない
いる場所さえも要りません
ですから もう宇宙はいくら破壊したっても
そちらには関係ない その心のエネルギーある限りいるんです
その場合は仏教では寿命は無数光年という
無数というアサンケイヤという数字で言ってるんです
無数と言ったってもちゃんとした数字があるんです
もしかすると十の何倍でしたっけ
十の もうとにかく百倍以上だと
百倍以上 後でもはっきり数字があるんだったらテキストが出てくると思います
私はあまり思い出せません
で 光年で数えているんですね
無数光年で それは無色界の場合
無色界の梵天の立場から見れば
自分がいるのみ 全く自分の心で他のものがいるということは認識することはできない
で 梵天も神々 我々人間も何か道具を持って相手に知らせるんですね
道具っていうのは物質なんですね
だから道具を持って指すところがないんですね
音も物質でしょうに 私は音を喋ったら皆様の耳に刺されちゃうんですね
それを それで自分が聞くという働きが生まれる
色界の梵天に体があるんだだからコンタクト取れるんです
ですからお釈迦様も色界の梵天に会って話したりとか
説法したりというストーリーがあるんだけど
一度も無色界の梵天に会ったということはないんです
会ってないんです 会えないんです
それはあまり仏教注釈書やらテキストやらあまり言わない
なぜかとかね で ほとんど言ってないんですね
お釈迦様が悟ってすぐ誰に教えようかなと思ったら
自分の先生二人を思い出したでしょ
誰にも教えませんと思ったところで
またそれも良くないと梵天に言われてもらって
で じゃあそれだったら誰に教えようかなと思ったら
やっぱりこんな高次元の教えを理解できるのは自分の先生二人しかないんだと
前のね その先生二人の無色界まで禅定を作っていた人々なのです
そこまで心成長しているんだったら
まあ悟りの道を教えられると思ってみたところで
一番年上の先生はもう 1週間前で亡くなっているんですね
歳も歳でしょうし あっ
もったいないと 時思ったんです
あの先生はもうすごい損しましたと
なぜならば もう何万光年とこじゃないです
そちらにいるのは また輪廻に戻ると
もうお釈迦様がいるとこではないし
もうどうなるかわからないんですね
もったいないことになったと
じゃあ次の先生にでも教えようかなと思ったら
その先生は次の日亡くなってるんですね
やっぱり仏性がなかったということなんですね
であ もったいないと お釈迦様寂しかっただろうと思いますけどね
じゃあ誰に言おうかと
次に誰に言おうかなと思ったら
ずっと自分の面で見てくれたこの最期の時は自分の家来でいたね
あの 5人に あの連中にでもなんとか教えてあげようかと
頭悪いんだけど しょうがないと
という感じになったでしょうね
ですから やっぱり無色界になったらもうコンタクトは取れない
綺麗に切られる 切断されちゃう
ですから誤解しちゃうんですね
それは輪廻の脱出だと
だからお釈迦様はこの観察能力
5つの瞑想能力によってパンチャシごじさいごじさい能力によって自分どんな状態にいるかということをちゃんと把握するんですね
だからひそひそ僧正を得た人はそれで喜んじゃえばもう解脱できなくなっちゃうんですね
悲壮悲壮情という禅定を作っても
パンチャシごじさいやらなくちゃいけない
ごじさい訓練して ちゃうと欠点見えちゃう
ここにも心があるんだと
それでヴィパッサナーしなくちゃいけないってことになっちゃうんです
そこで欲界の世界で 欲界ってのはすごい大きい世界なんです
地獄も神々も人間も入ってるんだから
欲界の世界で全ての心が現れるんです
全部全てのチット・ヴィーティが現れるんです
色界の世界で怒りの心は生まれません
怒りのチット・ヴィーティが現れません
それから可笑縁の心も生まれませんと書いてるんです
可笑縁はいつでもこの善・異熟・身だから欲界身ですね
それもないんだと それは色界
色界の梵天は怒りがないんです
だから他の人の宗教で
例えばイスラム教とかキリスト教とかね
もう絶対の神様がいると言ってるでしょ
その神様は仏教のこの世界次元から見れば低次元の神様なんですね
いわゆる神の次元の神なんですね
なぜならばすごい怒りを持ってるんです
すごい差別感を持ってるんです
梵天じゃないんです もし梵天の神様からコンタクト取られて
やっぱりそこで宗教を作ったならば
怒りがないはずなんですね
相手を倒そうという気持ちは
だからヒンドゥー教ではパラマアヒンサーという絶対的非暴力主義の教えが出ているんです
全ては同じですから もう倒すものは何もないんだと
敵がないんだと なぜならば
ヒンドゥー教の神様の概念というのは
単なる頭おかしくなって言ってるわけじゃないんです
で あの イエス様が現れる前のいろいろこの預言者というんですか
現れたでしょう よくストーリー読むとみんな頭おかしいんですね
ヨハネにしたっても なんかすごい頭狂ってる人なんですね
ですから そういう風な
まあ私たちにとってはそれはどうでもいいんだけど
そういう状態ではなくて
このヒンドゥー教の場合は
人々がわざと森に入って
山に入って 瞑想して 修行して
何か超自然的な体験を自分で体験して
それから喋ってるんですね
いわゆる梵天の次元に次元を体現してから喋ってるんです
ですから このヒンドゥー教の一部の宗派には怒りはないんです
ヒンドゥー教というのはすごい複雑なんです
今 現代ヒンドゥー教っていうのは怒りの宗教なんです
なぜならば 現代ヒンドゥー教はこの
あの 何ですか あのテキスト
テキスト バグアッド・ギータ
バグアッド・ギータという単なる詩なんです
あれは もう宗教のテキストじゃないんです
それを聖書として見ているんです
ウパニシャッドは聖書として見てない
その代わりにバグアッド・ギータというどこかの詩人たちが集めて書いた詩を
まあ詩人 詩でもそこに哲学があるのは当たり前なんですけど
詩は単なる馬鹿げたことを書いたとて詩になりません
だから もう日本のね あの
何でしたっけ 詩は何と言いますか
この こと忘れちゃった
和歌じゃなくて あれ 俳句とかね
言葉短いんだけど それなりになんとかもう哲学みたいなものをね
ある時もあるし ない時もある
もう最近書くものはもうただの
もう何のこともないんだけど
例えば日本でね 国際的な文化として残っているね
芭蕉の俳句はあれこれとか
そちらになんかちょっとしたすごい鋭い哲学とみたいな観察っていうのはね
あることは確かにある
ですから 詩には哲学あるのは普通は当たり前のことなんです
ですから マハーバーラタというインドの大きな物語の中で
ある一章に この ある一つのポイントだけに絞って
戦えと 囚われずに 心に囚われずに戦えと
我を捨てて戦えと いわゆるやらなくちゃいけないことはやりなさいと
それ以上考えるなということだと
それだけ言いたくて それはカルマ・ヨーガですよと
と言ってますけどね で
その場合はやっぱり戦えということは出てきちゃうんですね
行けという言葉が出てくるんです
ウパニシャッドはないんです
そんなことは あれはもう瞑想した人々の考え方なんです
それは言ったのはやっぱり
あの この 本物の宗教 なんか超自然的なところから何かコンタクトを取って喋ってる人の場合も
やっぱり誰からコンタクトを取ったかということは教えの中に入ってるんです
もし宗教の中で怒りやら嫉妬やらね
もう邪教の人をもう責めません
責め 責め-